in time-honored marvel tradition Black
Panther includes a couple of cool
post-credit scenes with teasers for
upcoming films yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
breaking down Black Panthers end credits
scenes to explain how they set up
Avengers infinity war and I'll also be
revealing some Marvel Easter eggs you
might have missed if this is your first
time here I do regular videos on Marvel
movies and I'm also starting my Black
Panther Funko pop giveaway for a chance
to win you just need to be a subscriber
and leave me a comment below with your
thoughts about the film quick spoiler
warning I will be discussing the end
credits scenes in full explaining their
link to the rest of the movie as well as
talking connections to and potential
speculation on Avengers infinity war the
mid-credits scene begins with T'Challa
attending the UN in Vienna and
delivering a speech to the international
community in the speech to Chara
announces that for the first time in his
country's history he's opening up
Wakanda to the world and offers to share
their knowledge and resources makanda
has up until now isolated itself using
its technology to hide its precious
vibranium resources in plain sight
first at the UN - Charla implies that
it's no longer right for candor or any
country to hide itself away in fact he
once were candor to be an example of how
we should all treat each other and as he
says in times of crisis the wise build
bridges while the foolish build barriers
in response one of the UN delegates
asked what Wakanda can offer the rest of
the world because in his eyes is just a
nation of farmers the scene stops at
this point with black panther Nakia and
Everett Ross all smiling knowingly at
the us of foolishness of that question
and Ross perhaps recognizes too just how
wrong he was earlier in the film when he
shared that delegates attitude still we
can assume that T'Challa would go on to
reveal that were Kanda has reserves of
vibranium and has developed technology
and medical treatments beyond what is
available anywhere else in the world by
taking this step to charla has acted on
the key is very real concern that during
her time as walk and inspire broad she
has seen too many in need to turn a
blind eye it's clear from the film that
opening up access to a condom medical
technology for instance as the potential
to revolutionize how people recover from
injuries as Everett Ross recovers from
being shot in the spine just one day
after being treated by Sheree access to
wakandan vibranium could be a
double-edged sword as although it would
likely be useful in the fight against
Thanos once the secret's out it could
attract other villains to try and get
their hands on it
as was the case with Ulysses Klaw and
along with Thanos his search for the
still to be uncovered soulstone that
could be another reason why we see in
the Infinity Ward trailer that the mad
Titan has sent his outriders to invade
the country but this opening up of
Wakanda also has huge implications
beyond Avengers infinity war as it means
we're likely to see future Marvel movies
crossover with black panther makanda the
world characters and tech of Wakanda are
so rich and ripe with opportunities of
storytelling that it seems likely that
Marvel will want to incorporate Black
Panthers world wherever it fits the
mid-credits scene is also a callback to
the UN so Cobie Accords meeting in
Vienna in Captain America Civil War
where two Charla's father king to
chacker addressed the UN and attempted
to make a similar speech offering work
and and cooperation and outreach to the
wide world
- Chaka was of course killed before he
could finish his speech when Zemo
orchestrates in an attack on the UN
building in order to frame Bucky and
this takes us to Black Panther second
and final post credits scene this has an
even more direct lead-in to Avengers
infinity war in this scene we find smoke
waking up in a small Hut in the wakandan
countryside surrounded by some
inquisitive children as the person steps
outside we discover it's Bucky who we
last saw being put on ice in the
mid-credits scene for Captain America
Civil War
Bucky agreed to be put under so that
were cannon scientists could figure out
what was wrong with his mind and in the
Avengers infinity war prelude comic we
learned that it's Shuri who's figured
out how to remove trigger words that
Hydra inserted in Bucky's mental
programming sure his treatment appears
to have worked as Bucky seems calm and
well he's also wearing a blue sling
around his missing arm in the scene and
at the end sure
tells him to come with her as there's
much for him to learn which likely means
they need to update him on what's been
happening since he was in cryostasis and
get him back in full shape we know from
the Avengers infinity war trailer that
Bucky has his missing arm restored at
some point so sure he probably still has
some more work to do on that and perhaps
it'll be made of vibranium too there's
also big hint to what Bucky's role might
be next in the name white wolf which the
children and the scene call out as they
run off white wolf was an interesting
Marvel Easter egg and a nod to the Black
Panther comic book character hunter who
was adopted by - Charlie's father -
Checker when his parents crash-landed in
Wakanda the white foreigner hunter aka
White Wolf loved his adoptive country
and eventually became head of the secret
police in Wakanda
so in this post credit scene Marvel
could be alluding to the MCU
Bucky taking on a similar type of
security role in Wakanda in the future
indeed in the Avengers infinity war
trailer book he looks like he might be
heading up a group of who condom
warriors on the battlefield and given
his past activities it would be a
natural fit for Bucky to take on black
ops star missions on behalf of black
panther Wakanda already operates a
network of spies or war dogs as they're
called and perhaps Bucky could join them
maybe teaming up with Nakia on future
missions it'll be interesting to see if
Bucky does take on the new identity of
White Wolf leaving behind his former
alter ego of the Winter Soldier or
whether this is just simply a nice nod
to the comics by the way given the
importance of sharees tech genius I want
to point out another way in which this
could link into the next Avengers
team-up
we know that Thanos pursues vision in
the infinity war movie and the mad
Titans Black Order are either seen
attempting to extract or manipulate the
mind stone in visions for head and it's
been rumored that vision gets taken to a
candor in the film so Cherie can extract
the mind stone from him and keep it safe
in the Avengers infinity war prelude
comic Cherie both attack she's develop
surpasses and I think Tony Stark has
done specifically how Stark created
Ultron which seems like another big hint
that Shuri could be involved in removing
the mine stone from
and keeping him alive at the same time
now if you've seen Black Panther what
did you think of the movie and the
post-credits scenes and have you got any
theories on what the end credits will
mean for Avengers infinity war or future
Marvel movies share your thoughts in the
comments below and also make sure you're
subscribed to enter my Black Panther
giveaway and if you enjoyed this you can
support my channel by hitting the thumbs
up button and sharing the video I really
appreciate all you do and I've got more
Black Panther and Avengers videos coming
shortly so why not hit the bell and join
the notification squad in the meantime
there's more Marvel and other videos
you're sure to like right here thanks
for watching and see you next time
you PK will be lovers